nous avons dû réagir c'est vrai que bon
tout le monde le faisait le constat y
compris les scientifiques de
l'université des antilles il ya même un
parlementaire qui prédisaient que le
prêcheur disparaissent dans quelques
années et nous disons souvent qu'il à la
fois raison et or il a raison parce que
si nous ne faisons rien ce sera très
vraiment le cas mais la tour parce que
justement nous avons décidé de prendre
le taureau par les cornes en faisant
quoi et bien en concevant projet
d'aménagement qu'on appelle en fait on
composait de recomposition spatiale en
partenariat avec un organisme une agence
un tennis et avec sa pelle plus qu'un
plan urbanisme construction architecture
l'adn martinique est aujourd'hui aussi
d'ailleurs l'agent des 50 pas
géométriques qui va nous accompagner sur
ce ce vaste e projette donc nous avons
effectivement décidé d'organiser de
recomposer spatialement notre territoire
déplaçant des populations pour que
sortiront de la frange littorale où
elles sont exposées aux risques
littoraux une partie de la population
que nous sortirons gagnants de l'ars
exposés au risque de l'art de manière à
aménager de nouveaux quartiers sur un
principe que nous appelons possible
habite à renouveler parce que pour ce
faire il ya une maîtrise d'oeuvre
sociologique urbaine et paysagère et qui
sociologique parce que justement la
population participer elle a été
entendue écoutée sur sa manière
d'occuper l'espace sa manière d'habiter
de manière à ce que les réponses que
nous apportons et ces phénomènes de re
re localisation ne sera pas trop
traumatisant et c'est pour cette raison
qu'elle était étroitement associés à
cette démarche est à partir de cette
maîtrise d'oeuvre urbaine et
sociologique donc on a hélas les maîtres
de vente élaborer ce qu'on appelle un
plan guide et qui nous permet justement
de repérer des lieux de réimplantation
des habitations des personnes exposées
aux risques littoraux et au risque
dollar